From this desk, seven and a half years ago,...
...President Bush announced the beginning of military operations in Iraq.
Much has changed since that night.
A war to disarm a state became a fight against an insurgency.
Terrorism and sectarian warfare threatened to tear Iraq apart.
Thousands of Americans gave their lives.
Tens of thousands have been wounded.
Our relations abroad were strained.
Our unity at home was tested.
These are the rough waters encountered during the course of one of America's longest wars,...
...yet there has been one constant amidst these shifting tides.
At every turn, America's men and women in uniform have served with courage and resolve.
As commander in chief, I am incredibly proud of their service...
...and like all Americans, I'm awed by their sacrifice,...
...and by the sacrifices of their families.
The Americans who have served in Iraq completed every mission they were given.
They defeated a regime that had terrorized its people.
Together with Iraqis and coalition partners who made huge sacrifices of their own,...
...our troops fought block by block...
...to help Iraq seize the chance for a better future.
They shifted tactics to protect the Iraqi people,...
...trained Iraqi Security Forces, and took out terrorist leaders.
Because of our troops and civilians,...
...and because of the resilience of the Iraqi people,...
Iraq has the opportunity to embrace a new destiny, even though many challenges remain.
So tonight, I am announcing that the American combat mission in Iraq has ended.
Operation Iraqi Freedom is over...
...and the Iraqi people now have lead responsibility for the security of their country.